[Musique]
voilà un discours qui risque de ne pas
plaire à tout le monde
ni aux policiers ni aux soignants ni aux
millions de français qui jouent le jeu
du confinement cela fait longtemps que
jean luc lahaye n'avait pas fait parler
de lui et pas sûr que ce retour dort
beaucoup son image il ya quelques jours
c'est sur facebook il répondait en live
par webcam à une interwiew une interview
dans laquelle il s'est confié sur son
quotidien depuis le 16 mars dernier et
l'injonction du gouvernement de rester à
la maison une injonction qu'il a décidé
de ne pas prendre en compte le
confinement très peu pour lui au cassis
normalement le confinement
je considère que c'est une immense
supercherie et ça ne regarde que moi ça
n'engage que moi avant d'en dire plus
sur son quotidien
je vis ma vie je sors en bécane tu mets
un masque parce que voilà oui je suis je
joue le jeu du masque mais point barre
sinon ça ne m'empêche pas de sortir et
voir mes empreintes
il précise qu'il ne peut plus non plus
faire de parachutisme mais uniquement
parce que son club est fermé un discours
à total contre courant de la période
qu'il assume et revendique pardon pour
ce qu'ils sont qui veulent rester dans
le cadre j'ai imaginé qu'il y en a bon
moi j'ai toujours fait de du hors piste
dans ma vie et m'obliger à me restait un
rester enfermée chez moi c'est
impossible
il vaut mieux mettre en prison ceux des
déclarations qui sont loin de faire
l'unanimité
alors qu'elle est choquée qui n'est pas
choqué bas les rives et l'ipad est très
très choquée quand il dit ça ne regarde
que moi ça n'engage que moi pardon
monsieur là et ça nous regarde pas que
vous ça n'engage pas que vous parce que
justement quand vous sortez et quand
vous êtes quand vous décidez par vous
même de vous des confiné d'une bombe à
retardement que vous êtes malade et vous
allez du coup rendre malades d'autres
personnes donc ça le gros nerf actu vous
vous êtes totalement égoïste
désolé après après après valérie vous
connaissez jean-luc la effet un rebelle
mine de rien c'est vrai qu'il a mais oui
non mais non mais c'est pas ça aux s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît c'est que il
a toujours eu la presse contre lui il
est bien son sang contre lui je pense
aussi qui fait un petit peu de
provocation jean lui parce que tous les
gens sont toujours des dons contre lui
donc il s'est dit tiens à mon avis je
vais un peu provoqué pour provoquer
aussi des réactions et peut-être pour
faire aussi par les nuits je sais pas je
pose la question
jean michel maire non mais je trouve ça
incroyable il dit j'imagine que les gens
qui restent dans le cas c'est bien
entendu été un peu de provocation
heureusement que les gens qui restent
dans un cadre 9% des français est en
quarts il aisé dernière ces études ont
prouvé que grâce au confinement
vous avez sauvé 90 personnes
heureusement qu'il ya pas des gens que
comme lui qui font n'importe quoi au
juste les gens restent longs cabaye à se
vanter d'être hors cadre donc alors
grenet grenet ouais alors moi que je
donne aux émergents à valérie et jean
michel moi ce qui m'énerve un petit peu
et j'ai toujours fait du hors piste
alors je voudrais pas corps vient d'être
prêt à faire comme pas eu de conclusions
déjà éculé mais ne te demande pas de
faire mieux en pixels caissière rebelles
c'est bien moi
mais le copinage je le respecte par
rapport aux autres
c'est vrai que j'ai d'ailleurs tu as la
guilde du provenge tu as la coiffure du
rebelle lorenzo lamas ce nom mais c'est
vrai thouars les hommes c'est vrai il
était flic qui faisait du bon boulot
mais il avait le commis l'erreur de
témoigner contre d'autres officiels et
macbook tournée c'est ce qu'avaient
tenté d'éliminer mais c'est la femme
qu'il aimait qui avait été cru tu sers
été touchées rappelait le sauvage accusé
à tort de meurtre il re dès maintenant
du côté du dakota aux renégats lorenzo
lamas le rebelle
allez ben justement après le rebelle on
aura le forcené dans un instant gilles
verdez d'abord ch
moi ce que je comprends pas je n'excuse
pas on est tous des rebelles
moi aussi je suis un rebelle moi aussi
j'ai envie de 2,2 m ben oui mais
justement je me rebelle plus modeste
ferme ma gueule et je reste consignes et
parce qu'on voyait tout le monde est une
exception
personne ne va jouer collectif on nous
demande de faire passer le collectif
avant des individualités qui a dit ça
c'est fait c'est aimé jacquet qui a dit
ça ces mégères exactement et voyez donc
ils s'envoient l'arrêtera faire alors
laurence haïm magnifique eh ouais le
magnifique
un merci c'est toujours un bonheur de
nos enfants
moi j'ai surtout je pense qu'il devrait
le mettre face à une équipe de
réanimation et une équipe deux fois
moins de gens qui s'épuise depuis des
semaines à sauver des gens à tous ceux
qui sont morts dans les ehpad qui
malheureusement n'ont pas été réanimé
donc on peut rire de choses on peut
faire son buzz
ok mais ce sujet là il est sérieux parce
que c'est un sujet de vie et de mort
et franchement c'est justement je pense
qu'en fait il est tellement perchée qui
réalise même pas la gravité du sujet et
la souffrance de tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont encore en train
d'essayer de se battre pour rester en
vie alors il a expliqué pourquoi il
n'aimait pas le confinement jean luc
lahaye regardes et tu est confiné tu
confies n'est apparu tendu
je suis moi qui suis quelqu'un est pris
de libertés totalement je considère que
ce mot engage un contrôle permanent de
nos déplacements
c'est comment comment le dire c'est un
mot générique qui ne déplaît pas être
confinée d'aborder en deux mots c'est
encore pire qu'on finit même on a l'air
de confier
non non moi je ça me déplaît énormément
ce ce principe des plaies ce mot alors
je le jeu l'excès qui m'obligeait à me
restait à rester enfermée chez moi
c'est impossible il vaut mieux mettre en
prison aussi jean michel voulait
renverser comme on sait qu il pourra lui
sinon évident personne n'aime le
confinement vous avez déjà vu des gens
j'aime bien qu'en filmant tout épris de
liberté
mais c'est vrai que c'est pas la
question du jour c'est pas un débat qui
de ceux ci on est tous épris de liberté
so franchement il faut respecter les
consignes de sécurité voilà jean luc
lahaye comme les autres yahoo qui vit
chez prix liberté bas la liberté moi
vous savez quoi
mme abbey liberté cbnm ma benhaim
longtemps jeté garder comme une perle
rare
c'est toi qui m'a marqué les abats aller
le soupçonner le fort ce but et
honnêtement on parle de guy on parle de
jean lucas et moi j'ai revu ce qu'il a
dit à gauche à droite céline câble ou
cheryl a eu un plateau géant plateau y
dit que des bêtises depuis 30 ans voilà
c'est sa faute de vrais bouts c'est pas
moi c'est pas bien c'est un gentil
garçon c'est un provocateur hilarant
mais attendez attendez
jean lui permet non je veux je vous dis
est ce que vous êtes choqués que
jean-luc ai dit ça non mais à la limite
c'est normal c'est dur le clae il dit
toujours des choses à contre-courant et
franchement c'est ça si il est toujours
comme ça moi j'ai en plateau il m'a dit
des énormités des conneries cheryl
pareil alors franchement la parole de
jean luc lahaye honnêtement quel est sa
portée à l'état c'est nul c'est une
façon de faire du buzz
non il a par des bus est encore
aujourd'hui le cas il ya beaucoup à
vannes on non médaille d'or
moi honnêtement venant lui je vois pas
ce catch o'connor ses sacs à main
benjamin là là là là je t'arrête là
dessus c'est vrai que jean-luc voilà
c'est un provocateur
mine de rien ça quelqu'un de très
sympathique dans l'abîmé jean-luc il a
énormément de familles nielsen moi c'est
le seul bémol c'est le gros bémol wind
en a aussi parmi ses que ses fans
peuvent se dire ah bah comme jean-luc
parce que ses fans les fans de jean luc
lahaye ils sont comme des fous sur le
lien c'est vraiment c est leur idole
absolue
donc il ici jean luc jeu permet de
sortir et que jean lui qui dit voilà moi
je suis épris de liberté
je vais sortir je vais faire des tours
en moto tous à eibar peut-être que les
mecs vous dire vas nous on va faire
comme jean-luc et il ay là il a beaucoup
de fans aujourd'hui que là et je peux le
dire
irene sur les jeunes bien sûr mais jean
michel faure
mais le forcené mais vous êtes vous
pétez une fois de pousser les câbles est
en train de dire que parce qu'on est
people on n'avait pas droit parce qu'on
est un peu origine
dans les bras droit si la sécurité à qui
a des fans que les gens respectent ça va
être un exemple pour ses fans
l'apa est un mec qui n'est pas moi je
prie de liberté je fais ce que je veux
et le forcené et rend toit en toit alors
merci oui gilles le forcené déraille
complètement pourquoi parceque vous
plaidé l'excusé de la singularité audit
presse qu'il est irresponsable mais
c'est ce qui dit qu'il n'est pas
responsable d'un jardin c'est parce que
c'est jean luc lahaye qu'il veut pas
dire ça vous vous dites
jean luc lahaye il a tourné les choses
comme ça mais non on n'a jamais vécu ça
on n'a jamais vécu cette pandémie on n'a
jamais vécu ce virus est près ce que
vous dites bon bah c'est pas grave c'est
lui qui dit mais cette règle a dit
benjamin castaldi
rendez vous compte que vous avez dit
bien le fond le forcené quelqu'un va
vous parler c'est valérie bénaïm c'est
la négociatrice d'accord le forcené
écoutez moi bien le forcené
il ne vous sera fait aucun mal si vous
respectez les règles voler les mailings
par les wikis le forcené c'est pas parce
que vous vous avez suffisamment de recul
pour prendre les paroles de jean luc
lahaye pense qu'elles sont c'est à dire
des énormités des bêtises plus grosse
que lui et parce qu'il l'ait dit depuis
plus de 50 ans que les tout le monde a
le même recul apparent c'est une
personnalité sa parole elle est publique
et sa parole donc elle peut porter et
donc on part du principe que sa parole
que porter et donc il ya une
responsabilité est donc un type comme ça
dix face caméra et et en étant fier en
plus de dire moi je ne suis pas les
règles assez moi je suis au dessus de la
mêlée et moi j'en ai rien à fiche qu'il
y a encore quelque 1500 personnes en
réanimation et que le nombre de
personnes en réanimation à baisser
confirmant c'est moi j'estime que le
continent aura six chiens et
l'appartement
pardonnez-moi le forcené mais c'est
inadmissible alors vous demandez aux
forcenés de vous pardonner un setter
valérie veine alors alors alors oui le
forcené oui alors il n'a pas appelé les
gens à sortir il dit moi moi je ne
respecte pas ce confinement pour des
raisons qui sont les siennes
après je cautionne pas du tout il a tort
mille fois je me replace par rapport à
la personne ce mec-là il a un parcours
il vient la dass et c'est moi je vous
dis que ce mec-là 10 jeux je me des
confine pas je refus de confinement et
qui je prends ma moto et je roule 8
cédulas et dans le texte n'a aucune
portée et ça n'a aucune espèce
d'importance
flory c'est une question personnelle à
vous poser à à chacun dit la vérité est
dite franchement dit la vérité est ce
que vous avez enfreint le confinement
depuis le début dit la vérité
racontez nous dit la vérité voilà juste
mais même une fois ou pas du tout mais
là non j'ai dû aller voir pour des
raisons très personnelles mes parents
voilà mais sinon je ne suis absolument
pas sortie depuis un mois et demi j'ai
même pour tout vous dire depuis depuis
un mois et le des soucis aux dans une
rage de dents qui me fait extrêmement
mal etc
voilà bah ouais voilà est là il me l a
une dent contre à l'âne donkey voilà il
donc qui est en train de vivre sa vie
quoi et la défaite très dure et par
téléphone mon dentiste m'a expliqué ce
que de se trouver faire pour essayer de
faire calmer la douleur et tenir jusqu'à
ce que son cabinet réouvre comme tout le
monde
donc voilà on passe droit que jamais moi
ce qui me fait mal c'est que bon je me
plains pas du tout mais alors ça vous
fait mal
ah oui je sais bah oui mais christophe
maillot s'il a dit ça alors oui et donc
qu'est-ce qui vous fait pas alors c'est
pas voir fada ça me fait ça mais ça
c'est pour ceux qui nous rejoignent oui
bah oui ma fiancée dose respecte
tellement le confinement que je vais pas
l'avoir donc quand j'entends ça
cependant moto essor oui ça me fait
encore plus mal d'accord mutuellement
jean-michel - moi je les offre deux fois
j'avoue je l'emprunt deux fois mais j'en
suis pas fier ouais je les fais deux
fois mais en tout cas voilà je ne suis
qu'à bout du tunnel de faits réels il
est honnête on est surtout là bas j'ai
été voir une copine une copine voilà qui
ont craqué les quadistes wario pour
travailler le lait la balle de sa thèse
sa thèse sa thèse elle prépare un terme
c'est vraiment parce qu'il ya des gens
qui sont confiées à plusieurs jeux
construit tout seul donc c'est vrai
cette bête je me plains pas du tout
monsieur richesse et posant par arriver
je les aime toi à puy de dôme
est-ce que tu as rooney et l'appui togo
fille il n'est pas allé qu il y ait pas
l'argent suite j'en suis pas fier et
j'incite personne à le faire j'ai fait
deux fois genre de jeu ce n'est pas dire
à vous gens sont bien plus qu'un papa
bravo pas bravo mais là où il est
honnête les travaux de ne pas citer une
enseigne dit la vérité
j'ai pas mon frère mais j'ai fait
quelque chose qui a un peu mal lu
c'est effectivement
atteint j'ai quand même pris leurs deux
tréteaux et en trois ans personne petit
trailer de sport a été autorisé parce
que c'est vrai c'est mal vu c'est vrai
malgré tout on croise des gens c'est
vrai les gens ne porte pas de masque
donc on se rend bien compte qu'elle
quand même un risque mais j'ai pris leur
de sport du matin d'accord rené ricol
s'est effectué là je sais que tu a
enfreint le règlement pour aller faire
une petite mise en pli mais ça on
t'envoie c'est normal qu'ils cherchent
c'est une émission nous a contactés mais
j'aurais bien aimé être comment c'est
sûrement parce que j'ai mon frère qui
fait graves à malade depuis dit d'aller
à l'ipc et malheureusement quel nom
alors moi quel jeune tam des rigolos
comme moi ça m'a mis les boules je
comprends amoureux des rené comme ils
s'appellent ton frère terre et non serge
pas je fais un gros bisou à chiens si
nous regardent et et un jour eh ben si
ça lui fait plaisir
si super marseille on ira le voir
ensemble on lui fera des on lui fera
démolir la ghetto à mon chéri pas je te
jure que c'est vrai et ben voilà
ok on lui fait un gros bisou à certains
moments benji n'ont jamais encore jamais
vraiment jamais mettre en jambes les
cerveaux mais maintenant tous n'ont même
pas dans l'idée m'a traversé l'esprit
effectivement de bouger avec ma famille
mais voilà mais je n'ai pas fait
effectivement en me disant c'est pas
bien de faire dont je n'ai pas fait je
reste à la maison
et voilà évidemment je n'appelle pas les
gens à ne pas sortir au contraire un
rapport à jean luc lahaye résultats du
sondage d'echery voilà regardez on va
voir le résultat du sondage des gens qui
avaient choqué 84% pas choqué à 16%